one of the first things
that i came across
in in doing this
was
that i figured out that being a vegan or
a vegetarian was probably not a good
idea how did you come across that like
how did you arrive at that well um
it has to do with protein intake um
and glutathione so glutathione is you
know i'll
i'll keep this brief not get too
technical but glutathione
is
the most important internal and
antioxidant that human beings have that
mammals have it's made by the way you
asked me the other day about what was in
my vitamin bag and they do inject
glutathione into the bag too right right
i saw that yes
um
so
what had happened in in my medical
odyssey was that
there were there were of course lots of
lab tests
done and nothing ever turned up
abnormal or not very abnormal anyway not
enough to explain anything finally
the one doctor did a test for
glutathione
and
um
this is a test that's not commonly done
in the lab like
you know it's a this is a special test
only a few labs do it
um
and it came back abnormal
um and so that was
kind of a revelation because it was the
first time that you know anything like
that had come back abnormal so i
i delved into looking at glutathione
glutathione is
a protein so it's it's a small protein
made of three amino acids so
where do amino acids come from they come
from protein
um and so if you
you know the idea being if you don't get
enough protein or enough of the right
protein you will be making enough
glutathione
there is actually some
uh
you know there are studies
about this that that
people who don't eat
meat
do have lower levels of glutathione
so anyway that was one of the first
clues
um and
yeah at that at that point at that very
moment i i was not totally convinced the
the the way i phrased it just now about
that i thought that
being a being a vegetarian or vegan was
not a good idea that was that was about
the most i could get was it a bad idea
uh well i didn't know at the time but i
thought
there's no harm in not doing it anymore
you know and at the time i was still
buying the whole saturated fat causes
heart disease kind of thing
not that i was in in any danger of heart
disease at the time but
anyway so i quit quit being a vegetarian
quit being a vegan and
um
felt better pretty quickly
um like like within the first couple of
days of eating meat or was it within a
week or two i wouldn't i wouldn't say it
was quite that quick but certainly
within a month or two i was noticeably
better
and what did you notice immediately like
what were the biggest changes from a
plant diet to uh i mean did you go right
from plant to carnivore or did you just
incorporate more meat into like salads
and stuff like that well well it was
more like uh so it wasn't going to
straight carnivore no it was more
more like a paleolithic diet and i i had
a few
stumbles there at the beginning because
one of the first versions i read about
the paleo diet
was from someone lauren cordain who was
big on
you know he still believed the saturated
fat stuff about heart disease you know
so i so i i read his stuff and decided
to follow that and i was basically
really hungry all the time doing this it
was it was that so it didn't last that
long that particular version
um
and then but then i went more to just
sort of uh you know meat and vegetables
uh that sort of thing um and got rid of
all the processed stuff all the
non-paleo stuff
um
with you know with a few exceptions
um and and felt better pretty you know
relatively quickly
for the people watching like what that
what that looked like on a daily basis
like was it steak chicken fish like
salads like what did you
right so uh
what would it be um it would be very
similar to what i'm doing now
so that would be
um yes i eat steak uh i eat some chicken
i eat some fish um i eat fermented dairy
products like yogurt
and cheese
and
i drink coffee and tea i drink red wine
i eat a few vegetables
um probably i'm not sure how many i
would eat if the lady of the house
wasn't uh cooking them and serving them
to me but i do eat some
um
so that that's what it looks like um
and
so in any case you know i i did feel
better i i was still fatigued and so on
um
but
at one point
i thought
you know
wow you know i i feel
you know on some particular day i i've
got some good energy here and
um i had wanted to take up weightlifting
again um i've i had done it a few times
in my life before
and
so i had an old barbell you know
sitting in my uh so you did no
resistance training on muscles at all
during the whole vegan time
i did do some yes um i would say you
know it wasn't the most effective way
you know based on what i know now and
i'm sure i wasn't getting enough protein
to you know support
muscle growth but i did do it
um but but my major focus was on running
um
so
anyway i p i picked up my my old barbell
and started doing a few things and
managed to eke out about 15 minutes of a
workout and it was exhausting
um and then i rested a day and then the
day after that i did it again
and
was feeling better it it felt good to do
that and and after uh
after a few weeks
of doing this i realized i needed
heavier weights
uh and so i went and joined a gym
it's something i'd never done before and
um and just kept at it
and eventually the first year
i did that
i put on you know 25 to 30 pounds of
muscle
um it was very rapid probably essential
it it is substantial i i came from uh
are you telling me or do you have a
shorter frame
um average okay right that's still quite
a lot of muscle especially for a guy
that's like well into his like middle
ages of his life right
sure sure it is um
i came from i you know i was very thin
to be to begin with right so
you know a lot of that was just working
out hard and eating like the picture you
have here on your twitter banner at 53
like that that to me looks like a
standard vegan runner
exactly and that's what i that's what i
was yes
right although by that time
i wasn't able to run because of my
fatigue but um
yes so so that photo you just showed
that is the base of you know that that's
where i started in in in my uh
weightlifting
and
um
so so i did it i put on a lot of muscle
in in the first year and felt really
good and and
then you know at some point
along the way i had told myself that if
i if i ever figured out
you know if i could ever get out of this
if i could ever fix myself
and figure out how you know how it's
done that i should write about it
so
at some point later on i was like all
well and i thought oh yeah i remember i
was going to write about it so i did and
so i i wrote a book first one it was
about chronic fatigue put it up on
amazon kindle and and then uh
after that
i was like well what am i going to do
now well i i guess i'll just keep
writing
and
so i did and um you know i have uh
started my website and
wrote some more books
eventually um ended up on twitter which
is my main venue these days it's just a
much more uh
you know i don't know ready readily
available
format to to get to people
um
and so
end of story that's that's that's my
origin story that's that's how i got
where i am here yeah i had no idea that
you were a vegan runner um for a length
of time i mean i just
um i mean i came across you about a year
or so ago i think and um
you know uh i've just found that the
content that you've put out it's been
quite useful especially when it comes to
self-care and and health and i mean you
seem to have the same sort of mindset
when it comes to life and everything
else too um
but the but the weight training for you
started at age 53 roughly
right that's that's right that's that's
when it started in earnest
and i don't know if you can answer this
because i mean you started at 53 but how
was weight training at at that stage of
your life as a guy different from
somebody that might be in their 20s or
30s
um i don't know that it is so different
um
you know there there
there are a lot of myths
around
uh age and exercise like especially
weight training that it's harder to
build muscle
uh
past a certain age past the age of 50
i've even seen people say oh i have
after 40 you know you can't do it and
this is not true at all
um yes there is some age-related decline
in the ability to build muscle but is
just not very significant at all that's
far from the um
dominant factor in in being able to put
on weight you just you know
you work out it
at its most basic level is you work out
hard and you eat right and you put on
muscle that you know that's that's how
it works so
um older older men do have
um
uh let's say let's say uh uh they have
to they have to watch their recovery
time better they need more recovery time
they need more recovery recovery time
exactly so if you worked out like every
other day let's say or did three or four
days a week when you're in your 20s
could you still get away with that in
15's and 60s
well in my 20s i could uh in my 50s and
60s so like right now i certainly can't
and
the the thing is
what i want to make clear is i i i don't
recommend that anybody do that that sort
of you know four or five days a week in
the gym working you know for too much
yeah i believe it's too much
and
and um
so yeah so you know but younger guys can
get away with that more
um i you know i believe in basically
minimally effect minimal effective dose
of exercise
um
that's going going to be the most
effective for you
so
this
um my my view on this as far as
how
much how often you should train
is partly
borne out by experience because i have
spent a lot of time
um
feeling not not so great in terms of
energy levels because i was working out
too much
i see this in my clients
quite often um where
you know this is this is especially true
of um you know
high performing men
they they want to exercise they want to
uh they want to be healthy and fit
and tend to go at it a lot so there
there are guys out there that are going
hard at it every day
and
they feel tired all the time and they
don't know why
and usually when i
you know when i find out about their
their exercise regimen you know that
that's the first thing to look at
um
if they're you know going to going to
crossfit four times a week or something
like that it's just a whole lot of
exercise
the
the amount of exercise
that you know and i'm i'm i'm going off
on a tangent here so you know feel free
to you know reel me back i'm listening
man
hey you know school me yeah okay
so the amount of exercise
that
is uh conducive to health and fitness
um
the the optimum amount of exercise is
surprisingly low
there have been some studies for example
where they looked at
runners
joggers
and
looked at them in terms of mortality
rates
and they found that
the the people who were
doing
something on the order of running like
a couple of miles at a time
two to three days a week had the lowest
mortality levels compare compared to
people who did no exercise
and then
when people did more than that there was
either no effect or a detrimental effect
similar thing has been found in
weightlifting where people who
did uh i i think it was a couple of
sessions a week had lower mortality
rates but they found that the people who
were doing four to five sessions a week
basically
the mortality was flat just as if they
weren't exercising at all
and certainly so
you know this this does get tricky
because you're looking at populations of
people
there's all kinds of factors involved
but certainly it's it's my view that
when you get up into things like
distance running for example marathon
running
um
you're certainly getting into
a level of exercise that is not
beneficial to health
um and and is is detrimental to health
so
uh you know there there have been uh
studies where they looked at heart
problems in marathon runners um so men
who had been running long distance all
their lives and you know found that they
had this um
you know fibrosis in their hearts
um and and so
you know there's there's a lot of
evidence that
um yeah that too much exercise is not
good for you what that level of too much
exercise is you know can be a little
hard to determine um
but
it's in in terms of
the way someone feels
um in their day-to-day life certainly
it's it is definitely possible to
exercise too much and a lot of people
are doing it
yeah i think your body like knows how to
tell you when you're going too hard on
it like i
i remember this um
this friend's cottage that i went to a
few years ago before all this coveted
stuff went went down and he goes yeah
you know bring your mountain bike up
there's some good trails up here and i
haven't i don't mountain bike that often
but i got a nice bike so i figured all
right let's let's go do it
and he took me out on it was like a two
and a half hour ride through
very hilly terrain and i got out of the
thing with my heart just pounding like
crazy and i was like this can't be good
like this is ridiculous like i'm
exhausted like my like my heart's going
a million miles an hour
yeah it was kind of fun but it was more
like torture
right and i felt the same thing you know
before when i would run because my dad
used to run you know when i was younger
i'd go out with him it's like you know
you do a few miles and i'm like this is
like this can't be good this is this is
getting silly
right right this this uh you know
chronic
endurance exercise um just seems to be
you know something that that well at
least it's not optimal
uh there's been a lot of interesting
work done in the last
couple of decades about high-intensity
interval training
so this is something like where people
um
when they do it in the lab this is how
they do it they sit on a stationary
bicycle with
you know uh fine-tuned control so they
have the the resistance adjusted just
right wired up to everything with a mask
and
well that that that particular thing
with a mask would be so for vo2 max
testing um but this particular protocol
for high intensity interval training is
just you know basically getting on the
stationary cycle and riding all out for
30 seconds
um and
some sometimes even shorter
so
there have been direct
head-to-head comparisons of
this type of exercise with
aerobic training cardio training in
other words
which is basically slow steady state
endurance training
it turns out that people so so they get
these guys in the in into the
gym or training center and they do this
uh high intensity interval training or
more specifically they call it sit
sprint interval training which when they
do it on the bicycle on the stationary
cycle
and
they do uh this one particular one where
they did
15 second all-out bouts on the cycle
interspersed with a few minutes in
between at low low intensity cycling you
know and then they do it again so they
did a total of four of these 15 second
intervals so a total of one minute
of intense exercise
not including of course warm-up cool
down and that low intensity in between
do that three times a week then they
compared it to people who
were uh running on a treadmill for 45
minutes
also three days a week and
the same
physiological changes were seen in both
groups
so
the one minute of exercise three times a
week did the same things in terms of
increasing fitness
as
spending all that time
on the treadmill running
so
intensity of exercise really matters a
lot
um it's a very important factor
if you get the intensity right the
volume and frequency of exercise can go
way down
so that that's how i look at it and
that's how i look at my
weight training as well yeah so your
personal strategy is one rep max
no not one rep max it's going to
momentary muscular failure so so it's so
it's failure but but but one um
but one set
one step one exactly two failure right
so if you're doing chin ups you'll do as
many chin ups as you can do until you
can't pull yourself up
exactly push-ups you'll keep pushing up
until you can't push up again right
exactly exactly right okay
um
yeah so you know that this is uh
uh a very different method of training
um it's been espoused by some prominent
people but it certainly differs a lot
from what the majority of people are
doing in the gym some of these prominent
people like mike metzer arthur jones
um
casey buyer
some others to
advocate this method and drew bay on
twitter uh also advocates this
um
and it involves intense exercise but
it's much much less frequent and and
lower volume
you